good morning everyone or a good
afternoon depending where you are um I
would like to thank the organizers for
giving me this opportunity to talk to
you today about choices for genetic
testing in particular about using
target-date sequencing and I'll focus on
two platforms microarray and
next-generation sequencing this
presentation is um eligible for
continuing education credits and there
will be link at the end of it for those
that wants to get some points for that i
also want to mention that there is
questions and answers that you can post
as i continue presentation so you don't
have to wait to the end but i will be
answering them at the end of the
presentation so what i'm going to talk
today about is firstly the learning
objectives for those that want to get
credit nature what is really the
sequencing why and when do we use it and
i'll talk about the technologies used
and also about how to go about
establishing our sequencing essay in the
lab so the learning objectives are
firstly to understand how targeted
resequencing is applied to genetic
screening or genetic testing and also to
appreciate the complexity of the
validation protocols for the rest
sequencing essays what is a sequencing
um it is a part it's basically a
sequencing of part or whole genome of an
individual and comparing this to a
reference genome for
particular species in our case we'll be
talking about human genetics so human
genome so when do we use a sequencing we
use it for a number of applications and
actually when you think about it Sanger
sequencing really was through sequencing
as well since you needed a sequence to
first design the Primus and then compare
your result to that when do we use it we
use it for carrier prenatal or newborn
screening we use it for diagnosing um
previously undiagnosed childhood or
adulthood diseases or disorders we use
it we use it also for risk assessment
for complex diseases and we have a
number of different methods we have
panels of genes exome sequencing or
whole genome sequencing we can use the
sequencing for genotyping for example
carrier screening or would be G note I
think we have a set of mutations that we
want to screen for but risk assessment
would be more of a fishing fishing
expedition does it will be variations
training we generally use snipper eyes
for variation screening but whole genome
sequencing is becoming more and more
popular especially with now 100,000
genome projects so not thousand genomes
we increasing that number how do we
perform targeted for sequencing there
are two main ways of doing this first is
to actually use capture of your target
DNA the 2nd a throw pcr amplification
using specific primers so what's the
difference when you capturing you need
to design products
and there are lots of commercial
products that you can use for this and
they are they're done in solution when
the products are linked to beats or
through or on arrays and in this way
after the DNA has been fragmented you
can basically pull out what you're
interested in easy unempl ification on
the other hand there is an amount a
number of different ways of doing it the
simplest is just multiplex pcr you can
use also Raindance fluid on hello plex
or any other proprietary systems from
any of that companies the main
difference here is that the primers that
you design have to be screened for slips
and repeat sequences so to ensure that
you can actually amplify cleanly what
you need to amplify now when we think
about genetic testing if we go back 10
or 15 years ago we all used for
sequencing purposes we all use thunder
and this was kind of a little slow one
gene at a time or one exit at a time and
if your genes were large that it took
quite a long time and it was quite
expensive and then as we started a
sequencing more and more genes for our
testing purposes it became obvious that
Sanger is really really expensive and
it's time consuming so for sa for
sequencing that it varies from one to
about se 1020 maybe even up to 40 that's
what I did you can use micro arrays
however when you move past a hundreds
into thousands of genes the only way to
go is with next-generation sequencing so
our sequencing becomes more calm
like from the low complexity of sanger
to really super-high with next
generation now there are a number of
essays available I did put in the stable
Sanger sequencing because there are
eight ers sequencing sets and if your
lab is doing a lot of single gene
sequencing the same over and over again
that might be a good choice for you to
use one of those when it comes to
microarrays there is really only one
commercial a panel right now the
pan-ethnic carrier screening panel the
free previously existing panels have
been moved now to next-generation
sequencing and when you look at the next
generation sequencing and trying to
bring this into the clinic you will see
that there is a number of essays
possible there is carrier screening also
a carrier screening panel but there is a
number others Noonan syndrome cardiac
disease from Michael genomics
neurodegenerative jerz multiple cancer
panels and you basically can pick and
choose and you can design your custom
ones as well now I'll go into technical
comparison of the two platforms so just
to start off with the sequencing
microarrays what they are and how they
work micro there a sequencing micro
arrays I they are based on the
affymetrix technology so a lot of you
are familiar with it and those that
aren't I'll explain a little bit more
about it those arrays come currently in
two different formats really one is the
traditional cartridge form in three
different sizes from 49 to 169 format
allowing you to sequence anything
between 47 to over 300 kilo bases
more recently the strips of four chips I
have been proven to actually work and
support the sequencing and those as well
as the 96-well plate of chips actually
require different equipment then the
traditional cartridge variety so there
are some choices that you had to make if
you decide to go this way as to what
your throughput is going to be now very
important part is how actually do their
sequencing does the sequencing work I
had this question as a lot of times and
I think something happened here because
this is looking a little strange I was
looking fine yesterday basically all of
the other metrics Prague's are 25 murs
and the way it works is that if you are
going to sequence from this see here
that are pointing with my arrow you have
to have the first 12 bases added to the
sequence from the gene from your target
gene and those will not be ever read by
the system because the FE requires the
first 12 bases of the buffer and it
starts reading the very first is the
13th base and the 13th base is the one
that's variable and you can have tgc or
a in the position if you look here we
have AG in our reference genome and an a
in a patient sample in this T this line
got completely out of whack here
you should be there under the a and
basically what happens is that you read
along the sequence so if you imagine
having your reference sequence child in
25 verse underneath and the 13th base is
always the one read this is really how
it works the problems arise when there
is a mutation and after that mutation is
passed then the mat there is a mismatch
to the left of your 13th base so if you
imagine just single base substitutions
that's usually not a big problem and
that can be overcome pretty easily with
the urbanization conditions the problems
arise when there are deletions or
insertions as they will really displays
the hybridization and when you using
three sequencing microarrays deletions
and insertions are really not something
they very well identify it is possible
but it's not recommended to really go
after those the other problem is repeats
as well as single base changes in
homopolymer stretches those are never
friendly with any sequencing technology
but micro arrays are particularly
susceptible to slippage of the
hybridization if you have repeats or
single insertions in homopolymers or
deletions for that matter another
problem is the large deletions and here
the problem is not as much with
identifying them as with designing the
probes and the essays if you know the
sequences of the breakpoints then it's
great you can design your probes
you can really identify those deletions
or at least attempt to do so if those
break points are not known then micro
arrays will be really really difficult
to use in such case now I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on the next
generation sequencing instruments there
is a whole variety of them that you most
commonly use for panels that I was
mentioned that i mentioned before our
alumina and ion torrent now how do the
sequencing workflow is compared with
micro arrays versus next-generation
sequencing in both cases we start with
genomic DNA kind of obvious and we end
up with some kind of data analysis more
or less complicated and the report
hopefully telling us what we had an
example now micro arrays are exclusively
dependent on pcr amplification and a
multiplex pcr that if you designing your
own essay and you wish to use rain dance
or halo plex you can try and experiment
with that I have no first-hand
experience with doing this but there's a
quilt but the equipment or the method is
quite expensive so you have to think
about how that will work for your essay
once the products are amplified the
pulling for purification needs to be
done and then remaining steps such as
pregnant asian labeling apodization will
sustain and scan follow normal as a
matrix product also there is no magic
you just keep on going on the other hand
the next generation sequencing requires
the genomic DNA first to be fragmented
and then depending on what protocol you
using you may need to tag those
fragments and then amplify with the
primers that are
proprietary or basically they not they
not specific for human genome soul
that's a bit of difference between the
microwave amplification and this step
here if you're using the target
enrichment with amplification then you
may need to you may tag them after it
really is dependent off on your protocol
once you have tagged big library then
you put it for sequencing and you and
you end up with some kind of data that
you can analyze so when we oh god I
really hate sometimes technology when we
actually look at the data it's those age
should be all aligned nicely under the G
what we looking for the g2 and a change
the other thing that you also see is
those random pain changes such as see
here and I see here and the G here those
are basically artifacts sequencing
single changes but you also see this
nice line of C's here that should be all
nicely lined up and it comes under the G
indicated that there is previously
undescribed polymorphism in that
position so it's very clear to identify
your mutation and possibly novel and
polymorphisms you get all of the
sequences read a line to your reference
and that is called death or coverage of
your sequence so it's kind
you see that there is a difference
between the microarray which actually
microarray gives you a FASTA file of
your sequence and this type of file that
you get from next-gen sequencing and
it's that format is the first q now I'll
talk about the pros and cons of each of
the technologies so microarrays what is
good about microarrays that you can get
a quick turnaround time and this is your
just your lab time 24 to 48 hours
depending on your workflow how long you
want to work during the day how many
ships you have in the lab and after that
you obviously have to analyze it and it
will add up a day or couple days
depending on how you want to process
that's the experimental protocol is
relatively simple it's just not
multiplex pcr and the differences
depending on how complex how many genes
you amplifying it will be added really
simple just one or two tubes or you will
have up to 30 or 32 wells in a plate to
amplify I think the largest I did was
about 800 or 900 amplicons in our
charcot-marie-tooth essay so there was a
lot of amplification so this protocol
wasn't as simple as it sounds once your
bio 4matic analysis optimize the results
are coming through really quickly that
five to ten minutes depending on the
speed of your internet on a cue that's
on server and if you comparing those
arrays to the snip erase that you might
be familiar with you actually end up
with sequins unlike the slipper eyes now
what are the problems with my parents as
I mentioned insertions and deletions are
a big issue and those arrays are not
really recommended for it
it definitely requires multiplex pcr for
amplification so timer design is a key
issue you may end up with losing some of
the results if your noise is not
consistent across the array and it can
happen due to a lot of various
unfortunate accident if you want to
modify your design because your panel
has changed or you want to add a gene
you just realize you missed or a
mutation you missed depending on your
throughput so your usage of arrays per
year that might be very costly because
you may need to pay for the mask and I
can add up it's also not a very rapid
change the other issue obviously is that
you can only detect what should tiled on
the Ray you cannot identify completely
novel mutation in the region that has
not been tiled now the problems we had
with the current essays that I worked
with word that partly the grated DNA or
whole genome amplified DNA then work
very well so ffpe sections and we're not
really pretty and this problem is
solvable by altering the multiplex pcr
conditions you have to have shorter
amplicons and then it works really
nicely now next-generation sequencing
some people think oh thats panacea will
be able to do everything we cannot do on
Sanger or on microarrays and that's not
quite exactly the truth the process
obviously we can detect insertions and
deletions delicious much better we can
detect novel mutations in areas that we
were not that we would not have
I on micro arrays but because we
sequencing the entire eggs on for
example not just the first 30 basis of
it we can see those mutations coming
through I will talk a little bit later
about the reproducibility and incidental
findings but the big the big plus is the
continuing to continue continually
decreasing price as well as ability to
actually multiplex more samples per line
so that's dropping the price down now
what are the negatives as I said it's
not an aserian for things that don't
work next-generation sequencing there
are areas for which you will not get
full coverage and this will create a
need for additional tests a the sample
preparations for complex divine 4matic
analysis is more complex primarily
because of the amount of information
that you have the other issue could be
the sequence length of the amplicons and
the sequence length that is up two of
the fragments are sequenced and let me
give you one example the kosher disease
DBA gene has a pseudogene and to get
around the problem we had to amplify
large 2kb amplicons it's obviously for
the next generation sequencing will not
work very well or at all the other
problem is kind of in analysis the risk
of over interpretation especially with
the variants of unknown significance so
just to summarize I did take time to
talk to people that actually used
microarray based assays and then
transition some of them to next
generation or develop new
next-generation essays and basically a
few points that a produce ability has
been highlighted to be definitely much
better on next-gen sequencing turnaround
time was a
majority case is shorter for microarrays
when it came to data analysis really the
differences we're in less accidental
findings but more pathogenic mutation
detected and also people notice that
they have higher cotton confidence in
the data that comes through and that
could be related first into the data
quality but also to the fact that we are
much more used to seeing sequencing
results and sequencing by hybridization
is a little difficult for people
initially to breast and then to become
really familiar with when it comes to
data quality definitely just detection
of involves insertions deletions is the
big glass and the other thing that I was
a little surprised was there are less
and calls because when you put all those
sequences together as we seem aligned to
your reference you can actually
eliminate the sequences that are poor or
the locations where there is a problem
validation is kind of pretty similar now
I put this nice report here for you just
to have a nice break and introduction
for next step we all familiar with
having your sequence nicely from sanger
having list of mutations what really is
the nature of the mutation sorry it's in
here and then what's the effect and what
is the change in protein when it comes
to both microarray and next-gen
sequencing reporting the critical issue
really for us was to identify the QC
points such as experimental PC and kissy
of the sequences conceived as sequences
for or your experiment was really badly
done this has to be repeated especially
in a clinic you cannot use something
that subpar
once you have that sequence all nicely
and clean high quality then independent
of whether you're using the micro arrays
or the next ten you have to align it to
the reference genome and it will be the
difference between aligning say 30 basis
or 100 basis to aligning the entire
genome or entire exome the very
important part is to actually filter out
nonpathogenic polymorphisms to clean it
up and then if you have a list of
mutations you interested it like for
example for carriers feeling we have a
list of say a hundred mutations we want
to detect we need to identify if they
are present or absent whether they are
homozygous or heterozygous and basically
the building of this report will be very
much dependent on each lab that has
their own preferences they want to do
their own thing and they have to
interact with the bioinformatics team to
make sure that everything they need is
captured in the report so now I can kind
of imagine the questions out there is
the what should I use you kind of say
this is bad and this is sometimes better
but sometimes not so good so if you're
considering at a sequencing as they for
your lab you really need to answer I
think those five questions and you will
be on your way to a decision how many
tests are you going to do per week are
you going to do ten tests are you going
to do a hundred or more tests if you're
going to do a lot of tests that probably
microarrays might be a little
challenging but not impossible so let's
look at the nature of mutations if you
want to just look at the substitution
mutations then you can choose either of
the methods
if you want to sa just a couple of jeans
or a few hundred mutations you can use
probably the micro arrays but if you're
looking at a panel of a hundred genes
then you definitely need to focus on the
next generation sequencing the some of
the labs I've noticed are very attached
to the equipment that already is in the
lab we already have the next generation
sequencer why would you buy another
metric system or vice versa so those
kind of considerations might be
important for some people also the time
required for implementation and I'll
kind of talk a little bit about this in
a moment now when you think about
establishing that sa in your lab it's
not really that different to any other
SI you've done before the first thing is
why do you why do you want to change why
do you need it what platform to use and
a few other things so I'll talk in that
kind of order here why would you want to
introduce nusa because you want to do it
faster better and cheaper sounds really
good to me and the next thing is you
want to streamline the test you're doing
right now tens or hundreds of tests
using Sanger sequencing so if you can
put them all in one method that would
take care of a lot of expense and time
you may say yes but we'll have to spend
time testing validating improving might
not be very useful but then if you look
at your competition and they already
using gene panels you may come reckon
siddur that fact here you also can
provide more comprehensive testing
obviously if there are two more
additional genes or five more additional
genes that can be tested for this
particular condition for example for
cancer there's more and more
coming that people want to test so that
might be useful also to meet more of the
clinical needs of the customers that
might be more important now when you
think about the whole process developing
in USA is a critical question here you
had a number of possibilities and
depending first of all where you are
located geographically whether you are
in the US or in other countries in
Europe or in Australia there will be
different regulations as to what can be
used and in many cases you can just buy
off the shelf as they optimize it for
your lab and be on your merry way in
other cases the labs tend to develop the
elder cheese because they are worried
about the regulatory landscape and I'll
talk about it in a moment too so once
you really the critical question here is
the content of your essay what is your
application are you doing carrier
screening are you screening for
pharmacogenomics are you screening for
cancer genes for particular cancers for
breast ovarian for stomach cancer for
brain cancers those panels will be
different so once you've decided on this
part and before you actually undertake
this you need to also consider what you
will need to validate you will need to
validate your platform make sure that
that performs well every time that it's
reliable then how will you go about
validating the essay itself what will
you need and then that IT the pipeline
for analysis
once you have those two pieces in place
or at least you know how you're going to
solve it you can start moving ahead with
actually doing it because implementation
will follow as long as you can create
those two parts here you are good to go
so choosing the platform here it's not
just next-generation basis micro arrays
that's the important thing that I've
been focusing here but once you have
once you decide either on micro arrays
or next then you need to decide on the
instrument type so even with micro
arrays where are you going with the
cartridges are you going with the strips
or plate type SI with the next
generation obviously there is no choices
the other issue that was pointed out to
me was also the enrichment method is
frequently associated with a big expense
so you need to decide what do you want
to use how do you want to go about it
and as I mentioned before the actual
development of an essay is a huge issue
for some labs because of the regulatory
requirements they need to meet that they
need to be sure that they can run this
essay tomorrow in six months and in five
years that the regulations will not
force them to change the essay again or
suspend performing the essay because of
how it was originally introduced so of
the shelf products do not work forever
lab you can work with a different
company that will help you with their
expertise to develop the ldt and all of
this will be you have to really look at
the time and the cost and very
importantly is there any documentation
from the companies
now when you look at the if there is
validation information from the
company's then it becomes really easy
for you to figure out how to go about
validating your own essay what would be
the values for your sensitivity and
specificity for your range for the
reportable range and the reference range
and what is the necessary coverage if
using the next-gen sequencing they will
have some guidelines so you don't start
from scratch you can actually know okay
I need this sensitivity or that many
genes I can report probably so let's see
if we can get to the maximum or we'll
have to settle on a little less then
it's been reported obviously I'm not
going to spend enormous amount of time
everyone that works in a CLIA lab knows
that the QC process of the performance
bags has to be done and that will do
that specific and technology specific
but it's critical information well we'll
come back to the proficiency test
thinking a little while because that is
for targeted resequencing it isn't
problem now one other thing we've been
talking about a reference genome and def
has been this is still being disputed
whether current reference genome we
possess for human is really a good
kingdom or not a good genome I think we
need a lot of more of whole genome
sequencing before we really be happy
with what we have is a reference but we
have to use what we've got so you can
agree or disagree the other part is the
reference materials and those are
critical for development validation and
on going to see and people tend to
ignore this and say oh yeah I have this
sample had been sitting in my freezer
for 10 years
it has those really precious mutations
I'll just use this to validate or test
my new essay and from experience I would
say bad idea because the DNA would be
degraded you don't know how well your
essays reading working so you should
start with well-characterized samples
and I'll show you in a moment where
those samples can come from so you can
have genomic DNA which is preferred
because it's similar to the patient
sample synthetic DNA is not really
representative and unless it's the only
option is proof it's recommended that
it's rather not used and obviously for
data analysis you need electronic
reference materials now where do the
reference templates come from they there
has been a lot of work going into making
discussing the reference materials and
making it more uniform across all the
labs because it became obvious we don't
have them ready so correo offers both
cell lines and purified DNA that has
been recommended for certain diseases
actually has been reviewed and
characterized by GE t RM and those
samples and those lists can be actually
obtained and used as your reference now
we've developed the essay with validated
it and now we goin into implementation
and all of a sudden we realize gee we
didn't fall about the regulatory thing
so I suggest really strongly to look at
this part first just at least to get
yourself familiar with how you will
implement it what is the regulatory
requirement currently the FDA does not
regulate genetic testing however they do
regulate direct-to-consumer testing they
don't like that and I don't think that
any self-respecting geneticist would
like that to that someone is given their
whole genome and said okay do you both
figure it out yourself so there are
issues with the regulations but you do
have clear and state regulations you
have different countries have different
regulations now there are some guidance
documents that really need to be looked
at and some of them are very helpful and
they know they not redundant so they
really address different aspects as I
said one thing that all the clear labs
need is proficiency testing and
basically at the moment there are no
formal programs for next-generation
sequencing or for that matter for an
aristocrat star get the tree sequencing
so for micro arrays also there is for
expression microarrays but not for
targeted sequencing so that's up to all
of the lads although guidelines might
come up soon the other a little slippery
slide is the reporting guidance and
basically if we have a list of mutations
that need to be screened either
recommended by ACMG that's fine we
screaming we're reporting however if we
have incidental findings it seems that
we bouncing from all we should report
them irrespective of the patient's age
we should not afford them so the
guidance
right now is to report them however I
wouldn't think that it won't change and
again we go into state and country
specific regulations here finally you've
got your results you return the results
of the clinician that ordered the test
and according to ACMG is the ordering
the Orient clinician is responsible for
providing the counseling so it becomes
very clear that the world we need for
more education for everyone how to
handle the next generation sequencing
how to explain incidental findings and
not overdo it so in summary we don't
have one method that will solve all of
our problems both methods have their
good side and bad sides and targeted
sequencing is really going I think ahead
with a lot of panels for particular use
for uncle James for carrier screening
for particular diseases and I see this
as a future really where it's going
development and validation are complex
though you have to take care of your
reference you have to make sure you have
the genome reference you have the
template reference and you'll cover the
things that aren't covered with
alternative tests and reporting can be
really painful at the first development
but once it developed it it will be very
easy to do okay that's the end of the
presentation for those of you that are
going to claim the credits you can go to
this link to follow the questions
and I had here questions already coming
through and buzzing on my desktop so
I'll go into some of that the first
question that I had here is with all the
assumptions and speculations involved in
sequencing technologies what are the
chances of errors in case of sample of a
sample in case example is subjected
again for sequencing percent accuracy of
saturated sequencing um okay with the
next generation sequencing I don't have
hands on a answer for you a with from my
talking to people that actually done it
they say that it is really high they
didn't really mention the numbers but
they hundred percent of them said that
it is much more reliable than microarray
breaking the dress sequencing so I would
speculate that it's at least ninety nine
percent but that's my guess and if
someone disagrees President Lee please
don't yell at me right here but it will
be in very nine in very high 90s and all
the microarrays that percentage of
accuracy with repeated sequencing a
varied but it was also very high I would
venture to say that it was at least 90
95 to ninety-eight percent depending on
his samples so samples that her that had
mostly substitutions were 98 99 percent
samples that heard either poor initial
template quality and even though seeing
them does tended to being more
error prone so there are differences not
just because of the technology but also
because of the quality of your sample
and I think that's really really
important the better your sample is the
better your results will be no matter
what is the platform the second question
here is could you pls highlight cost
comparison also so um cost for um if you
want to buy the microarray sequencing
essays those were a varying depending on
which I see you were looking at is from
I don't want to lie here I would say
from about two hundred dollars per sa
upwards it dependent on the size of the
essay so on that ray when we talking
about the next-gen sequencing I don't
have that information right on hand so
but if you're interested I can either
point you to the people that will know
that or you need to ask labs that are
actually running this type of screening
right now now the next question do we
need to confirm again by Sanger
sequencing after finding a variant by
microarray I had this question coming
through a lot and really the good
practice is that yes you do now
obviously if you find in our carrier
screening for example we were finding
usually about three each person would
have maybe three variants maybe four um
and you exactly know which ones you have
to sequence so I
say it's not a big deal if your sample
reports like 20 then first of all look
at your pc before jumping into
confirming bystander some lads have have
said that day not going to do some your
confirmation and I think at the initial
validation stage you have to do it once
you're really confident in your essay
you may get away without it but as I
said good policy is to do it okay next a
next question coming here is how can one
use next-generation sequencing in
disease diagnosis where the disease
pathogenesis is not associated with gene
mutation oh that one is an interesting
question so if there are for example it
might be due to a differential
methylation or other regulate regulatory
aspects so you can use different type of
next-gen sequencing essays but you would
have to exclude first that it is not
associated with a gene mutation so once
you excluded that you can move forward
with using for example chip essay or
methylation screen so there's
differential methylation in and that's
causing the pathogenesis okay if next a
question is what next-generation
sequencing platform platforms are
clia-certified if none of the next-gen
next-gen sequencers are clia-certified
can we use the results for clinical
decisions
I'm not exactly sure because if your lab
is a CLIA lab there will be a particular
recommendations how to make what do you
need to do to certify your sequencers
for use in a CLIA lab so I would
recommend talking to the labs that are
running the next-gen sequencing and in
Toronto there is a lab that does um the
it's a core lab and you basically they
are a clear certified lab so all of
their instrumentations would be
certified I'm not exactly sure what
you're getting here at so the whole
process would have to be adherent to the
CLIA regulations not just the
instruments so check with your provider
or if you have your own instrument then
I would go through and make sure that
you have all of them reagents that there
are all the specs are up to scratch so
you create your own got your own rules
and make sure that it's just the same as
with your Sanger sequencer just follow
similar rules i'm pretty sure i'm not
off the mark here but i would check with
one of the providers and if you want to
i would have to look for who would that
lab is and I don't see any more
questions coming through here so i would
like to thank you everyone for attending
this I hopefully gave
some idea of what is out there and what
to do with it I know I haven't touched
on everything but it gives you a start
as the word goal and this presentation
will be available I think for download
as a PDF as well as you can listen to
this again if you have any questions I
can be found round on lab roots and just
please be free to contact me through
there thank you very much